allez vous défendre et ben je défie qui
compte qui comme dans Cyril toi le
premier si demain je dis moi j'ai vu une
vidéo de Cyril en train de violer Gilles
Verdez
tu
deux hommes se sont introduits chez elle
et ont mis le feu à sa maison
heureusement on n'a pas été blessé mais
elle est très choquée elle était avec sa
maman deux fois on a essayé de mettre le
feu à la maison ils ont eu le feu ils
ont mis de l'essence partout autour de
ma maison déjà Maëva tu as quel âge
Maëva 25 ans 25 ans ça fait combien de
temps que tu fais la téléréalité
heureuse dans tout ce que tu fais ou
est-ce que parce que je sais que tu t'en
prends plein la gueule aussi alors je
suis heureuse mais c'est hyper compliqué
parce que il y a le bon côté des choses
mais il y a aussi le mauvais côté ça
fait plusieurs fois que j'ai subi des
agressions à Marseille on m'a braqué
une agression avant qu'on revienne sur
cet passé de cambriolage un braquage et
là on a essayé de mettre le feu chez moi
c'était l'anniversaire de ma mère et on
est sorti du Nord resto
et après on est parti boire un verre et
là il y a il y a le service d'alarme qui
m'a téléphoné en me disant qu'il y avait
des gens à la maison je suis directement
rentrée chez moi ensuite il y a le voix
mon voisin qui m'a téléphoné en me
disant que il y avait le feu chez moi
qui l'avait appelé les pompiers et en
fait au moment où enfin quand j'étais
sur la route
il y avait des vidéos qui circulaient ou
les gens qui ont fait ça ils vont filmer
ils ont fait tourner ça sur les réseaux
sociaux il m'a insulté et ensuite j'ai
compris que en fait on est venu
m'agresser chez moi enfin mec le feu
chez moi quoi
et ce sont des gens alors on va voir la
vidéo qui sont mis derrière regardez
ça fait quelques mois que je me fais
menacer sur les réseaux sociaux et là
c'est vrai que ces derniers temps
vendredi j'ai reçu on m'a menacé
et le lendemain il s'est passé ça donc
donc je sais pas si c'est cette personne
mais la veille on m'a dit qu'on allait
qu'on allait me tuer je te centrer
triste
à cause de moi et ça me fait de la peine
parce qu'elle simule ça à cause de moi
mais parce que tu l'as mise dans tes
vidéos aussi oui tu regrettes
en fait le truc c'est que les gens ils
pensent qu'on est parti vivre à Dubaï
par rapport aux impôts moi je paye
toujours des impôts en France bien sûr
et en fait c'est plus pour la sécurité
parce que en France en fait toutes les
personnes connues ben elles vivent pas
en sécurité on se fait cambrioler on se
fait braquer alors qu'à Dubaï ça
n'existe pas à Dubaï je la porte de chez
moi je ne l'ai jamais fermé à clé et je
dors la fenêtre ouverte vous êtes
évidemment une victime dans cette
histoire on peut souhaiter à personne de
vivre ça mais qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que vous
montrez trop justement votre vie privée
et aussi toute cette opulence qui peut
être prise par certains comme de la
provocation sur les réseaux sociaux non
mais en fait c'est notre vie de montrer
en fait moi j'ai pas de Tal un chanteur
son talent c'est de chanter donc il est
suivi par des millions de personnes
parce que parce qu'il a un talent moins
j'en ai pas moi les gens ils me suivent
parce que ils aiment ma personnalité et
qu'ils aiment ma vie donc je suis obligé
de de montrer ma vie ouais moi aussi
d'une fille qui se fait violer elle
porte trop courte elle a le droit de
gagner de l'argent elle a le droit de le
montrer alors d'avoir ce qu'elle veut
encore une fois elle l'a pas volé
mais c'est ça ça c'est normal
pas tout le monde peut m'aimer
très grave
on peut s'interroger là-dessus c'est pas
cautionner les incendies arrête de faire
le parallèle horrible avec le viol enfin
c'est c'est ignoble de faire ça on peut
se demander si aujourd'hui quand on est
très jeune et qu'on gagne beaucoup
d'argent oui ça suscite des jalousie oui
vous savez que vous récupérer énormément
de gens et donc c'est normal de se faire
de se faire un sandja de se faire
braquer parce que donc en fait quand tu
habites en France comme il y a pas de
sécurité tu as pas le droit d'avoir de
l'argent moi je soutiens les questions
de Guillaume parce que on vous exposant
comme ça je suis désolé vous prenez des
risques de mon point de vue inconsidéré
chers
à Dubaï non non non pas de ça à Dubaï
vous vivez dans un environnement hyper
privilégié entre influenceurs dans des
endroits de luxe non non mais ça c'est
pas vrai
vous pouvez pas comparer vous louez à
Dubaï vous êtes propriétaire je loue et
je vous montre combien par mois combien
par mois
c'est pas le même monde c'est pas le
même monde
déjà à Marseille en location
aujourd'hui est une scie potentielle et
doit quitter la France ou dois aller à
Duba sécurité c'est ce que tu es en
train de dire à la base c'est toi je
n'ai rien d'avoir réussi et je suis fier
de montrer que que j'ai réussi dans ma
vie ta mère est fière de toi oui
vraiment ouais
mais c'est bon en fait assis-toi non non
non moi je veux être gentil avec tes
faune tu n'es pas quelqu'un avec moi
mais je suis désolé
Greg Guillotin est avec Tiphaine qui a
joué sa copine dans le piège qu'on vous
montre dans le prank où on manque depuis
quelques minutes Eugène et Brigitte sont
avec nous
euh Eugène t'avais vraiment envie de le
défoncer
des moments comme ça je ne sais pas dans
mes tapé un câble oui j'ai pété j'ai
pété un petit peu oui c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui t'a fait qu'est-ce qui t'a
fait monter en pression
non c'était bon manque de respect bon
manque de respect c'est pas ça
Brigitte toi tu bouges pas
tu es calme toi tranquille
un petit un petit un petit touche quoi
c'est ça à la fin je n'ai Brigitte son
descendus ils ont adoré c'était trop
c'était ça c'est fini dans la bonne
humeur franchement c'est le meilleur
prendre de Greg Guillotin et ce qui est
très fort c'est que d'habitude dans les
caméras cachées le piéger pète les
plombs juste avant la révélation et là
dès le début Eugène il part en quart de
tour donc en toute la caméra cachée
pendant 1h30 grecque il marche sur des
œufs et là j'ai l'impression que c'est
la première fois que tu as eu vraiment
peur en fait je suis même à un moment
donné sorti de mon personnage c'est à
dire qu'à un moment je devais tellement
adoucir les choses que c'était plus le
MC Guillaume que j'avais prévu dans le
piège parce que j'avais plus aucune
façon de canaliser jeune qui croyait en
plus que le portail était fermé alors
qu'il était ouvert à la fin il va
chercher la police mais bon ça c'est
après mais du coup moi je voulais juste
qu'on finisse le piège et qu'au moins ça
puisse se terminer bien et tout
je suis pas bien je suis l'être humain
tout ce que j'ai vécu depuis un an je
suis malheureux je suis pas bien il faut
me laisser tranquille il a une casse
trop nouveau accuse aujourd'hui les
médias d'avoir ruiné sa vie il témoigne
ce soir dans TPMP alors on a eu hier
Maëva gaina
candidat de téléréalité et on a
l'impression que pour tous c'est vrai
que c'est la folie enfin moi dans mon
cas après chaque histoire est différente
encore une histoire différente
elle va bien on l'a vu voilà mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a on avait volé sa maison
on a tous l'impression que à chaque fois
il arrive des drames il y a eu plein de
déposer suite à cette histoire qui a été
parce qu'il en fait un moment donné
comme il y avait rien dans cette
histoire contre moi ni Victor alors
c'est pas de victimes il y avait une
vidéo soi-disant on disait vidéo la
vidéo la vidéo j'avais dit il y a un an
sortez là et ça ne sortirait pas ce que
ça n'existe pas ça fait un an on va
rappeler l'histoire toujours rien dans
notre milieu quand il y a quelque chose
ça sort ouais faut arrêter de dire
peut-être ça sort moi je suis j'ai pas
des pouvoirs magiques quand il y a une
vidéo d'un truc il y avait une histoire
de télé je pars au mieux écouter en plus
c'était des amis
mais quand il y a une vidéo ça sort faut
arrêter de croire tu peux pas cacher
quand c'est quelque part ça sort un
moment donné moi ça a fait quand même le
tour il y a rien alors
on va dire Ilan il est super fort il a
réussi à cacher la vidéo ok bon je suis
fort il y a quand même pas de victimes
pas de vidéo pas de formation oui
diffamation accusation calomnieuse je
suis accompagné d'un avocat comment tu
as vécu toute cette histoire c'est un
cauchemar pour toi
le lundi j'étais Ilan
je vous dis la vérité j'avais tout le
mardi il y avait plus rien
et en plus je me faisais insulter par la
France entière ma famille se faisait
insulter par la France entière
menacé de mort menace antisémite j'ai eu
le droit à tout moi tout tout tout on va
te crever chez toi ça le Juif on va
venir violer ta mère on va violer tes
petits frères j'ai eu le droit tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer et ça fait un an que
ça dure ma mère ça fait 8 mois qu'allons
plus mon père il a des soucis de santé
dû au stress mes parents ils habitent en
Martinique là-bas ils ont un bon job ils
ont pas de problème dans leur vie par
contre moi je suis devenu un problème
comment tu gagnes ta vie aujourd'hui
les réseaux sociaux
c'est fini je gagne plus ma vie avec ça
ça fait un an mais en un an en Ferrari à
Cannes
il sortait d'une suite en Martin
d'augmenter tes amis
chez moi ou c'est pas vrai
alors dans mon malheur c'est que toutes
mes années télé j'ai construit moi j'ai
pas dépensé mon argent j'ai payé mes
impôts et j'ai pas dépensé ce qui fait
que ça m'a permis de survivre après
survivre en Ferrari
et va et vous savez quoi allez-vous
défendre et ben je défie qui compte qui
comme dans le premier si demain je dis
moi j'ai vu une vidéo de Cyril en train
de violer Gilles Verdez
je me suis retrouvé dos au mur ou à un
moment donné je vous dis la vérité à un
moment donné c'était compliqué je
pouvais plus payer ce que je mon train
de vie ne suivait plus j'ai créé trois
boîtes pour m'en sortir je suis pas je
suis tout le monde pense que je suis un
branleur c'est la vérité j'en suis pas
je bosse vraiment réellement j'ai monté
trois sociétés et pas des sociétés on
dit ouais j'ai fait non non une société
de transport j'entends d'ouvrir un
restaurant à Nice à un Dubaï et j'ai une
société d'achat de revente de montre ah
c'est bien et la moitié est en France où
je paye mes impôts en France
j'avais pas besoin de ça et moi ce que
j'aimais c'est pas ça moi ce que
j'aimais c'est ma vie faut pas tout
répondre aux gens qui disent que la
fille qui n'a pas témoigné c'est parce
qu'elle a peur je donne un exemple il y
a une fille qui a porté plainte suite à
tout ça parce que une personne l'a
poussé à aller le faire
je suis pas au-dessus de la justice 7
mois d’enquête une confrontation 15
personnes interrogées classées sans
suite mais classer sans suite pas pour
manque de preuve classer sans suite
parce que ce qu'on m'a reproché c'est
infraction non caractérisée ça veut dire
que même si je l'avais fait je l'ai pas
fait
je peux aller bien 5 heures dans la
journée mais je vais voir une seule
petite insulte ça va me
ça va me tuer parce que en fait c'est
pas celle-là c'est tout ce qu'il y a eu
avant
j'ai pas le temps de comprendre que je
reçois des coups très tranchants la
coupable présumée dans cette affaire
selon lui une journaliste de télévision
mais aujourd'hui la jeune femme souhaite
livrer une toute autre version et
apporter de nouveaux éléments à cette
histoire connaissez bien signé Wana vous
le connaissiez bien dans cette affaire
ce n'est pas notre ami c'est quand même
important de souligner vous dites notre
ami parce que vous parlez de votre
conjoint
ce n'est pas l'ami de notre famille on
est on ne le connaît pas ce monsieur qui
a dit qu'il connaissait votre conjoint
mais en fait pas tant pas plus que ça
d'après vous non pas du tout d'accord
pas du tout si Léana affirme que vous
pétaradier autour de du square et en bas
de sa clinique pour vous à aucun moment
il y a une nuisance sonore pas du tout
et on le voit bien comme comme le montre
la vidéo je suis en train de me garer
je suis déjà à l'extérieur mais pourquoi
et donc là je ne sais pas je ne suis
plus dans la voiture en fait je ne
comprends pas je ne comprends pas nous
avons deux places de parking et les deux
places sont à nous donc je suis garée à
ma place derrière pour mon frère qui
sort de la voiture
et donc à ce moment précis je ne sais
pas pourquoi est-ce qu'il vient ouvrir
la portière le moteur ne tourne pas je
suis alex je suis déjà dehors c'est quoi
l'échange là vous vous dites quoi à ce
moment précis il a des propos très durs
sur quoi ça le négresse on va vous faire
sortir du square vous n'avez pas votre
place au square à ce moment précis
est-ce que vous voyez que je lui crache
dessus est-ce que vous voyez que j'ai
une attitude agressive est-ce que vous
voyez que ce monsieur ciné Ohana et par
terre et roué de coups par mois pardon
non à aucun moment j'ai une attitude
agressive à aucun moment au contraire je
dis à Brandon de fermer le portail qu'on
rentre à la maison il pousse sa
secrétaire à plusieurs reprises elle
essaye de le contrôler de le maîtriser
il force le passage de chez moi il veut
en découdre avec moi il veut rentrer on
est dans notre cours on est à
l'intérieur de ma maison
je vais nous avais ramené d'autres
vidéos on voit l'assistante de ciné qui
en plus lui aurait donné un coup
malencontreusement l'assistante elle lui
a donné un coup de coude qui sans faire
exprès voilà je ne sais je ne suis pas
médecin je peux juste je peux juste vous
dire que je n'ai pas cassé le nez de
Sydney Ohana et que ce geste de son
assistante aurait pu aurait pu et à
certainement casser son nez en tout cas
ce n'est pas moi j'ai voulu me défendre
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un problème
avec une autre voisine c'est ce qu'il
avait dit ici aussi cette voisine en
l'occurrence elle est considérée
d'après ce qui se dit dans le soir comme
la petite amie de Sydney Ohana ce n'est
pas mon problème mais je vous raconte ce
que c'est ce qui se dit
Johanna son assistant de la voisine ont
porté plainte madame il faut quand même
le préciser cette dame ok elle
interpelle le chauffeur pour lui dire
les nuisances sonores sont
insupportables on n'en peut plus
j'entends cette dame se plaindre à aucun
moment je me dirige vers elle pour lui
répondre je continue ma vie je récupère
ce que j'ai à récupérer dans ma voiture
et à ce moment là son chien vient zapper
auprès de moi et je fais un signe avec
mon mon comment dirais-je ma jambe pour
pour l'éloigner sans même le toucher et
cette femme court vers moi le point levé
me menaçant qu'elle allait également
en découdre avec moi je suis venu
l'histoire en tant que témoin et agressé
je suis pas venu vous raconter ma vérité
mais la vérité car il y en a qu'une et
concernant donc la question que vous me
posez Cyril drone en fait n'est pas venu
voir Madame Stevenson parce que c'est ce
qu'on voit sur les images et on le voit
en fait qui essaie d'ouvrir la porte
parce qu'en fait la cible première du
docteur Wana c'est la voiture c'est le
moteur c'est le bruit c'est pas il a
même pas vu c'est à dire qu'il est passé
à côté il a même pas vu et là je le vois
donc je vois docteur wanna madame
Stevenson suivi de son frère devant donc
juste devant la voiture et docteur
Rouana disait que le bruit c'était plus
possible qu'il donc les gestes qui qui
montent sur la vidéo qui disait voilà à
l'étage il y a des passantes qui se
plaignent elle a commencé donc à nous
cracher dessus donc je lui ai dit mais
en fait enfin vous nous crachez pas
dessus là je suis venu pour calmer les
choses on peut parler calmement donc
elle voulait rien savoir elle continue à
insulter etc et c'est de là après
docteur Rona bah il s'est énervé et j'ai
essayé de calmer moi je me suis pris des
coups est-ce que j'ai du mal à
comprendre sur la version que nous a
donné le docteur et là je je crois
quelqu'un arriver quelqu'un à ouvrir une
voiture et vouloir éteindre une voiture
moi si tu me fais ça je vais dégoupiller
tu rentres pas dans ma voiture pour
éteindre ma voiture déjà tu as pas à
faire ça déjà et après je vois quelqu'un
rentrer dans la maison de quelqu'un il y
a une agression mais il y a une
agression peut-être provoquer par
Monsieur le chirurgien c'est peut-être
lui qui a provoqué ça en fait non en
fait moi je vous adore mais vous êtes
son ancienne salarié vous êtes là voilà
on sait pas si c'est un bon patron pour
vous quel est l'intérêt de rimes non
mais je sais pas journaliste a évoqué un
lien entre la dame qui aurait été
agressée dans l'après-midi et le docteur
est-ce que est-ce que ce lien existe
réellement et est-ce qu'il y aurait
absolument pas j'ai été témoin et
agressé et on m'accuse d'avoir porté un
coup de coude le coup de coude
c'est quand même un coup tranchant il a
eu une déplacé enfin il est ouvert c'est
clairement pas moi
Nicolas Gironde un magasin à Forbach
vous avez fait énormément parler vous
n'en pouvez plus des vols vous avez
décidé d'afficher les voleurs sur les
réseaux sociaux
pas trop vous avez fait ça Nicolas
c’était un coup de gueule un ras-le-bol
ouais c'était vraiment quoi toi tu délis
je j'en peux plus
ça arrive régulièrement ouais ils ont
pas peur de la justice ceux qui font ça
et ils se sentent intouchables bien
souvent ils sont intouchables donc tu
t'es dit moi je vais les afficher voilà
on se dit on va essayer de les faire
culpabiliser un peu de honte pour eux et
pour nous ça apporte ses fruits on a
retiré la plainte on a retiré nos images
on a récupéré nos articles on espère que
ça servir aux autres de leçons et voilà
et ça a porté ses fruits ça a porté ses
fruits et deux jours après ceux qui
volaient ils nous ont ramené les
articles incroyables on dit toujours la
même chose ceux qui veulent ne risquent
absolument rien pourquoi ne ferait-il
pas donc c'est le moment je veux même
pas aux gens qui sont malhonnêtes j'en
veux à la justice de rien faire donc
évidemment qu'il faut il faut en arriver
là c'est à dire qu'il faut encore on en
arrive au fait que c'est à nous et
nous-mêmes de faire juste
ce soit à nous de faire la justice en
tout cas c'est quelle société que tu
proposes donc une société
il a prouvé que ça fonctionnait ils sont
revenus pardon pour une pas quelque
chose fonctionne problème c'est que à
partir du moment même si la justice est
laxiste même si à mon avis faut que les
lois changent on ne peut pas malgré tout
se substituer
le donneur de leçon faites mais c'est
pas une question de donner
quoi mais vous allez tous vous ouvrez
beaucoup vos jambes on n'a pas de
solutions c'est vraiment tout le respect
que j'ai pour la police mais je vais te
dire moi j'étais cambriolé ils sont
venus ils ont regardé s'il y avait deux
trois empreintes je suis allé au
commissariat je dirais pas lequel je
suis arrivé JS qu'on va retrouver les
trucs qui m'ont dit non j'ai dit
pourquoi parce qu'il m'a dit on ne
changera pas voilà ce qui m'a dit je te
jure que c'est vrai ils peuvent pas ils
ont pas les moyens autre chose à [ __ ]
que les chercher ils ont pas les moyens
ils ne peuvent pas faire ça donc il y
aura pas d'enquête pour effectivement de
boîte de conserve et pour ce monsieur
qui a perdu 100 €, il y aura pas donc ce
qu'il faut faire en sorte c'est qu'il
n'y ait plus de vol puisque de toute
façon on ne peut pas les condames alors